every Skylanders game has had a
different hook from giant characters to
supercharged vehicles and Skylanders
imagine aters is no different I'm Tony
and this is your custom-made GameSpot
news update Skylanders imagine aters
will let you design your very own
characters and some players will even be
able to 3d print their creations
activision has said that printing
supplies will be limited and the company
will run promotions and competitions
around the game's launch but even if you
don't end up with a physical character
you can get a credit card sized item
with all of your characters details that
can then be used with the Skylanders
portal and that's about all the details
Activision has shared at this time
Skylanders imagine aters is coming to
ps4 ps3 xbox one xbox 360 and wii u on
October sixteenth it's the sixth game in
the series and it also marks the debut
of the legendary Crash Bandicoot as a
playable character tune in to game spot
on launch day to see our impressions and
for all the biggest toys to life news
you're already in the right place
you